miguel tracked how much sleep he got for
50 consecutive days and made a histogram
of the results which interval contains
the median sleep amount
and so they're saying is it this
interval on the histogram from 6 to 6.5
or this one or this one or any of these
which of these intervals contain the
median pause this video and see if you
can figure that out
all right now let's work through this
together and let's just remind ourselves
how we find the median if i had the data
points 11
7 3 and 2 the way that we find the
median is we can order it from least to
greatest or actually you could do it
from greatest to least but let's do
least to greatest so 2 3 7
9 11 and the median would be the middle
number and i have a clear middle number
because i have five data points
if i have an even number of data points
i still would want to order them from
least to greatest so let's say that i
have a 1
and a seven
but here you don't have a clear middle
so the median would be the mean of the
middle two numbers
so in this situation miguel has an even
number of data points so the median
would be the mean of the 25th
and 26th data point
these would be the middle two data
points so which interval here contains
the 25th and the 26th the data point
well we can start at the bottom
so we have actually let's just look at
each interval and think about how many
data points they have in it this one has
two this one has nine
this one has
12 and i'm just reading out how many
data points there are in each of these
intervals
this one has 12.
this one has
11. i see that there this one has two
and this one has two
so if we look at just this we have the
two lowest if we look at the two bottom
intervals combined we have the 11 lowest
if we look at the three bottom intervals
we have the 11 plus 12 you have the 23
lowest
so this is the 23
data points
and so
the 24th 25th 26th the next 12 data
points starting from the bottom starting
from the lowest are going to be in this
next interval here and we care about the
25th and the 26th so they're definitely
going to be in this interval from 7.5
hours of sleep to 8 hours of sleep